Dark Souls. Where do I start?
For the better part of a year,
A huge part of my life has revolved around this game.
If I could sum up how i feel about it in one video,
then I wouldn't have seventy other videos dedicated to it.
And if there's any one true testament to what this game means,
then you should just look at the content and the community
that has evolved around it.
But essentially, Dark Souls, to me,
is what a video game should strive to be.
Because games have the potential to be something that nothing else can.
Not only can they put in control of a character or a world,
but they can give you an experience.
They can use gameplay and interactivity to make you experience the world.
Good games realize that you aren't just a viewer,
you are a player.
And carefully - very carefully,
true games can be designed so that the player doesn't just witness the world around them,
they experience it.
A book can't do this.
A movie can't do this.
Sure, these mediums can make you empathize.
But they can't make you experience.
Only a game can do that.
I want this game to be the one that reminds us what some games can be.
So I'm going to spend these next few minutes reflecting on what Dark Souls is.
Think about Dark Souls.
Really think about it.
Do you remember your first play-through?
You're dropped into this world with no idea of what's going on.
So you do what feels natural, you know?
You progress,
you struggle,
you fail,
you struggle again, and you succeed.
One day you struggle for so long that you might even give up completely.
And you leave this game behind.
Now think about what I said in relation to the story of Dark Souls.
You're an undead. You can never die, but every death brings you closer to hollowing.
Your mind is fading and you're in this cell with no idea what's going on.
So you take the only option open to you.
You progress, you struggle against the world, you fail,
you struggle again, and you succeed.
One day you struggle for so long that you give up completely.
Because undead can never die but every death brings you closer to hollowing.
And once you've hollowed completely, you lose all hope.
So the reason I said a similar thing twice
is because the gameplay just mirrored an experience.
This is the story of an undead who gives up hope,
and it's the experience of a player who fights against Dark Souls.
This is a game that has depth because it focuses on the experience.
And Dark Souls is known as a difficult game.
It's the story of an undead human in a world where everything is out to kill him.
A world where dying as this undead is a traumatizing experience,
that you have to try and push through.
Just like dying as a player is an irritating experience that you have to overcome.
So it makes sense, you know?
That you should have trouble progressing in this game sometimes.
What a lot of people don't understand is that Dark Souls isn't difficult for the sake of being difficult.
Its difficulty comes as a result of a deeper design philosophy,
From Software have actively designed their game around something that only games have:
A failure state.
Death in video games is something we take for granted at this point.
But in Dark Souls, death and failure are designed to give you that feeling of struggle and triumph.
It's also used to immerse yourself in a world where death doesn't end your life,
but it brings you closer and closer to giving up.
People often say, 'it's too difficult,'
or, 'it doesn't explain things to you,'
these are insults leveled at the Souls series regularly, and...
They're right.
Dark Souls is too difficult for some people.
Dark Souls also doesn't go out of its way to explain things to you.
But here's something you have to understand about Dark Souls,
it's a game that doesn't dumb down the experience for the benefit
of the so-called 'mass-market appeal.'
It does its own thing, regardless of whether some people will be turned off, and
in doing so it's become something infinitely more valuable and pure.
From's philosophy revolves around making this good game first,
and trusting that people will come, and
this has happened, slowly, you know?
Demon's Souls came out, and it was a niche hit,
Dark Souls came out, and
even two years after the game came out, people are still picking it up
due to word of mouth.
As a result, the Souls series doesn't need huge marketing efforts behind it,
because it's become this industry icon through word of mouth and people telling each other they should play it.
You know, someone said something really great to me, recently.
He said, 'You know, From Software, they aren't afraid to put things in their game that people will miss.'
And, that's such a perfectly beautiful statement.
If I had to choose any statement that represented Dark Souls, I'd probably choose this one.
It's the reason the game has so much depth,
because they don't compromise on game design, just so every player can see an area,
or so that every player can understand and play their game as soon as they start.
When I say that you might not see certain things, I'm not just talking about how
the DLC is located in a hard-to-see cave near an optional boss that can only be accessed
if you kill certain enemies in the right order.
No, I'm also talking about how they don't shove the story down your throat,
or how the game locks you out of certain areas if you're not good enough to beat them.
Let me explain that better.
Imagine if you were reading a book.
You're reading a book and then all of a sudden the book shuts itself and says 'Stop!'
'You're not good enough to read me!'
'I'm going to lock away parts, so you have to earn them.'
Dark Souls sets itself apart from other game in this way.
And this is just one of the reasons it's come to be considered a 'pure' gaming experience.
It's something, I think, that could help games  remember what they can be.
I think games should, generally, focus on what makes them different from other forms of media.
And that's something that From Software has captured in... A lot of different ways.
But Dark Souls doesn't just lock you out of content by being difficult.
In fact, I think one of the biggest reasons Dark Souls is considered difficult
is not because it's 'hard,' but because it's hard to get into.
And while I see this as a bit of a problem, since they plan to fix this in Dark Souls II,
and make the game more accessible,
some fans will even argue that the inaccessibility of Dark Souls is a plus,
because it makes those first few hours of torment and struggle even more rewarding
when you finally learn how to play.
But it's not just the gameplay in Dark Souls that's cryptic.
And anyone who's on my channel knows this.
Dark Souls also approached the concept of story in a game in a unique way.
The story elements are cryptic and hidden down to the last little detail.
And while you might have some idea of what happened by the end of the game...
Most players actually just end up thinking,
'Why the fuck am I on fire?'
There's actually a beautiful little story behind why the souls games were created with these cryptic, hidden stories.
I'm sure many of you have realized this, but
Dark Souls is a western-style RPG created in Japan.
And that's a bit strange. It even has English voice-actors to convey this feeling more accurately.
So, why is this? Why is this a vision?
Well, when Miyazaki, the game's director, was a child,
he loved reading western fantasy.
He loved the stories, the settings, and he was inspired.
And so Dark Souls was created in this western RPG format.
But, there's more to this story.
Miyazaki couldn't read English very well,
so when he read these western fantasy novels, he had gaps.
And you might be able to see where I'm going with this.
Some parts of these books, he just couldn't read.
And so while he had this vision of decaying castles and brave knights,
he had to use his imagination to fill the gaps.
And in doing so, he created a story that was partly his own.
And a story that was richer because of this fact.
Sound familiar?
When we play Dark Souls, we create our own stories.
Just like Miyazaki did.
We read item descriptions, we listen to dialogue
and from the bones and fragments of a story, we slowly, carefully craft this vision of a world.
Some people, like me, bring this vision to life through videos.
We call this vision, 'lore.'
Some of us share our lore with others, and discover other people's stories on image boards and forums,
inspiring and challenging great ideas.
And this is what has kept this incredible community alive way longer than you'd expect.
By creating a game that intentionally leaves things for you to discover and speculate on,
we now have one of the strongest communities on YouTube.
And we exist across hundreds of pages of forums and wikis.
There's a reason people were still coming into this game years after the initial marketing push.
It's because, we in the Dark Souls community talk about this game.
We share our experience and there are thousands of people who play,
just because they get that comment from a friend that says,
'Dude, you have to play this game,' or
when someone says,
'You haven't played Dark Souls?'
I can't imagine not having a friend to talk to about my experiences in this game, you know?
The thrill you get when your world is invaded by another player, or
the venting of frustration that you have to do when you've been stuck on a boss for four hours.
And then the eventual ecstasy you get when you overcome and obstacle that was in your way,
it's just one of those games that was destined to find a home on the internet.
Full of people who need to share and tell others about this experience.
And in this way, the game actually kind of sells itself.
I recently got invited to the Namco-Bandai offices in San Jose in the states,
and I managed to meet al these people who were behind the marketing of Dark Souls and Dark Souls II.
And, the thing is, they realized that this game is different.
They realize it has this effect on people where word of mouth will sell their game.
And really, they just have to allow From Software to fulfill their vision.
And I can't think of any better publisher to publish this actually.
I met with Bryan Hong who's the director of marketing for Dark Souls and Dark Souls II,
and he put it so well. They don't have to change Dark Souls to suit the market.
Just like Apple didn't create a PC to suit the market,
the market eventually realized their vision and came around to them.
And that's what I think is happening with Dark Souls.
And I think that this is a game that will come to define a generation.
And I'm actually honored to be a part of it with you guys.
Soon, you'll be able to click here and kindle the bonfire so that we can make this channel better together.
In the comments of this video, I'd love for you to tell me your favorite little piece of gameplay design in Dark Souls.
I could have made this video much longer if I talked about all my favorite mechanics and bits,
but I decided to keep it short, but sweet.
For example though, I could quote so many beautiful pieces of gameplay design
from the design-works book.
And these have interviews with the director and developer, so
I think I might just read one of my favorite quotes right now,
so one of them is about his design of the undead, uhh, the undead dragon.
And, he says,
and Miyazaki says,
"Most people don't believe me when I say this, but a certain kind of refinement,
"elegance, and
"dignity are very important to me.
"I usually tell the designers that flat out grotesque or splatter-type design will not get past me.
"This has everything to do with my own personal sensibilities and it's something that I apply to every design that I approve.
"It's a little hard to describe if you were to ask me... Well, what do you mean by dignity?
"I guess the best answer I can provide you is right here, in this book.
"In every design in Dark Souls you see within these pages,
"My idea of dignity is something I pursue with every project I work on."
And then one of the other designers tells a story, he says,
"I remember when I was drawing the undead dragon.
"I submitted a design draft that depicted a dragon swarming with maggots, and other gross things.
"Miyazaki handed this back to me, saying, 'this isn't dignified. Don't rely on the gross fact to portray and undead dragon.'
"'Can't you instead try to convey the deep sorrow of a magnificent beast, doomed to a slow and possibly endless descent into ruin?'"
And, like, just look at how they succeeded with this in terms of design.
This is an undead dragon.
Doomed to live the rest of its life clinging to cliffs while its brethren fly through the skies,
and instead it's here, rotting away.
If you aggravate it, it tries to breath fire, but vomits out bile and poison instead.
I challenge you guys to look deeper into every aspect of design in this game.
And, for example, where some people just see a rotting dragon,
others will see that deep sorrow of a magnificent beast, doomed to die a slow and possibly endless descent into ruin.
Anyway, I'll catch you guys next time as we dive head-first into Dark Souls II.
There's going to be so much content on this channel, so keep your eyes out.
Later.